at long last justice for the 96 for
their families for all Liverpool
supporters for an entire city what it
took too long in coming and the struggle
for it took too great a toll on too many
now those responsible must be held to
account for 96 unlawful deaths and a
27-year cover-up thankfully the jury saw
through the lies and I am sure repeating
what my the Meritor friend said the Home
Secretary that this house will join me
in thanking the jury for devotional
estas and giving two years of their
lives to this important public duty when
it came their verdict was simple clear
powerful and emphatic but it begged the
question how could something so obvious
have taken so long three reasons first a
police force which has consistently put
protecting itself against over and above
protecting people harmed by Hillsborough
second collusion between that force and
a complicit print media
third a flawed judicial system that
gives the upper hand
to those in authority over and above
ordinary people let me take each of
those issues in turn starting with the
South Yorkshire Police can the Home
Secretary assure me that there will be
no holding back in pursuing prosecutions
the cps has said that files will be
submitted by December while we
understand the complexity can she urged
them to do whatever they can to bring
that date forward of course the behavior
of some officers while reprehensible was
not necessarily chargeable but through
retirement police officers can still
escape misconduct proceedings in her
policing and crime bill the Home
Secretary proposes a 12-month period
after retirement where proceedings can
be initiated but one of the lessons of
Hillsborough mr. speaker is that there
can be no arbitrary time limits on
justice and accountability so will the
Home Secretary work with me to insert a
Hillsborough cause into her bill ending
the scandal of retirement as an escape
route and of wrongdoers claiming full
pensions and will she join me in making
sure it applies retrospectively the much
bigger question for the South Yorkshire
Police to answer today is this why at
this inquest did they go back on their
2012 public apology when the Lord Chief
Justice quashed the original inquest he
requested that the new one not
degenerate into an adversarial battle
sadly mr. speaker that is exactly what
happened
shamefully the cover-up continued in
this Warrington courtroom millions of
pounds of public money were spent
retelling discredited lies against
Liverpool supporters lawyers for retired
officers through disgusting slurs around
those for today's force tried to
establish that others were responsible
for the opening of the gate
if the police had chosen to maintain its
apology this inquest would have been
much shorter but they didn't and they
put the families through hell once again
it pains me to say it but the NHS
through the Yorkshire ambulance service
was guilty of the same does the Home
Secretary agree that because of his
handling of this inquest the position of
the South Yorkshire Chief Constable is
now untenable does she further agree
that the problems go deeper
I promise the families the full truth
about Hillsborough I don't believe they
will have it until we know the truth
about all grieve this force used the
same underhand tactics against its own
people in the aftermath of the miners
strike that it would lay to use two more
deadly effect against the people of
Liverpool
there has been an IPC C report on all
grieve but parts of it are redacted it
has been put to me that those parts
contain evidence of direct links between
or grieve and Hillsborough this Mr
Speaker is a time for transparency not
secrecy time for the people of South
Yorkshire to know the full truth about
their police force so will the Home
Secretary accept the legal submission
from the or grief truth and justice
campaign and set up a disclosure process
this force hasn't learned and hasn't
changed mr. speaker let me be clear I
don't blame the ordinary police officers
the men and women who did their very
best on that day and who today are out
there keeping our streets safe but I do
blame their leadership and culture which
seems rotten to the core or grief
Hillsborough rather room how much more
evidence do we need before we act so
will the Home Secretary now order the
fundamental reform of this force and
consider all potential options let me
turn to collusion between police and the
media the malicious briefings given in
the aftermath were devastatingly
efficient they created a false version
of
which lingered until yesterday no one in
the police or media has ever been held
to account for the incalculable harm
they caused in smearing a whole city in
its moment of greatest grief imagine how
it felt to be my constituent Li walls
who came through gate C just before 3
p.m. with his friend Carl Brown Carl
died but Li survived but days later he
had to read that he was to blame given
the weakness of the press regulatory
system back then the survivors of this
tragedy had no ability to correct the
lies well is it any different today mr.
speaker if a tragedy like Hills but were
to happen now victims would not be able
quickly to undo the damage of a
misleading front-page Leverson
recommended a second stage inquiry to
look at the sometimes unhealthy
relationship between police and press I
know the Hillsborough families feel
strongly that this should be taken
forward so will the government end the
delay and honor the prime minister's
promises to the victims of press
intrusion
I turned to the judicial system I have
attended this inquest on many occasions
I saw how hard it was on the families
trapped for two years in a temporary
courtroom told to show no emotion as
police lawyers smeared the dead and
those who survived beyond cruel and I
welcome bishop james new role in
explaining just how cruel this was to
the house and to the country
the original inquest was similarly
brutal but that didn't even get to the
truth just as the first inquest muddied
the waters after the clarity of the
taylor report so this inquest at moments
lost sight of the Hillsborough
independent panel reports one of the
reasons why it produced a different
outcome though is because this time the
families had the best lawyers in the
land if they could have afforded them
back in 1990 history might have been
very different at many inquest today
there is often a mismatch between the
legal representation of public bodies
and those of the bereaved why should the
authorities be able to spend public
money like water to protect themselves
when families have no such help
so will the government consider further
reforms to the coronal system including
giving the bereaved at least equal legal
funding as public bodies this the
longest case in English legal history
must mark a watershed in how victims are
treated mr. speaker the last question is
for us in this house what kind of
country leaves people who did no more
than wave off their loved ones to a
football match still sitting in a
courtroom 27 years later begging for the
reputations of their sons daughters
brothers sisters and fathers the answer
is one that needs now to do some deep
soul-searching this cover-up went right
to the top it was advanced in the
committee rooms of this house and in the
press rooms of 10 Downing Street it
persisted because of collusion between
elites in politics on both sides police
and the media but this Home Secretary
stood outside of that and today I
express my sincere admiration and
gratitude to her for the stance
she has consistently taken in righting
this wrong
but my final words go to the
Hillsborough families I think of those
who did not live to see this day of the
courageous and Williams of my
constituent Steven Whittle the 97th
victim who gave his own ticket to a
friend on the morning of the match and
later took his own life I think of
people like Phil Hammond who sacrificed
his own health to this struggle I think
of the many people who died from outside
Merseyside recognizing that this was not
just Liverpool's
but the country's tragedy I think of
legal out Carl Brown and his devoted mom
Delia who still visits his grave most
days I think of Trevor and Jenny Hicks
and their heartbreaking testimony to the
new inquest but I think most of my
friend Margaret aspinall she didn't just
sacrifice everything for her own son
James she took on the heavy burden of
fighting for everyone else's loved ones
and by God didn't she do them proud
it has been the privilege of my life to
work with them all they have prevailed
against all the odds they have kept
their dignity in the face of terrible
adversity they could not have shown a
more profound love for those they lost
on that day they truly represent the
best of what our country is all about
now it must reflect on how it came to
let them down for so long